blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so we have a new but somewhat
predictable wrinkle in the entire
discussion that's now happening around
the democrats infrastructure bill social
spending bill and this debate that's
happening not only between democrats and
republicans but also within democrats
trying to
bring senators joe manchin and kirsten
cinema on board with getting
something passed at some point
relatively soon
the new wrinkle is that there are
reports that joe manchin is considering
leaving the democratic party
which joe manchin has immediately denied
and said rbs which to me
doesn't really mean much at all
and is almost predictable that joe
manchin would deny it because just the
rumor floating
is probably enough to achieve
what one might imagine joe manchin would
want to achieve by threatening to leave
the democratic party
which is to push democrats to say whoa
whoa whoa okay okay it's sort of like so
you people are having an argument one
person pulls out a gun and everybody
whoa whoa okay no yeah but you're you're
good you're good uh so let's talk about
it first of all the report is in mother
jones by david corn david corn has a
good track record i i tend to believe
that at least david corn's report is
believable now whether someone lied to
david corn okay you could talk about
that uh 20 hours ago scoop mansion tells
associates he's considering leaving the
democratic party and has an exit plan
he could pull the trigger if he doesn't
get his way on the build back better
bill
um
in recent days joe manchin has told
associates that he's considering leaving
the democratic party if president joe
biden and democrats on capitol hill do
not agree to his demand to cut the size
of the social infrastructure bill
basically in half from 3.5 trillion to
1.75 trillion according to people who
have heard manchin discuss this
manchinis said if this were to happen he
would declare himself an american
independent not a republican and he has
devised a detailed exit strategy for his
departure this is a little too detailed
to imagine it's all made up
i'll give you my thought as to what is
actually going on
um mansion told associates he has a
two-step plan for exiting the party
first he would send a letter to senator
chuck schumer the top senate democrat
removing himself from the democratic
leadership of the senate he's vice chair
of senate democrats policy and
communication committee manchin hopes
that would send a signal he would then
wait and see if that move has any impact
on negotiations after about a week he
said he would change his voter
registration from democrat to
independent now here's the key question
about all of this
it is unclear whether in this scenario
mansion would end up caucusing with the
democrats which would allow them to
continue to control the senate
or side with the republicans and place
the senate in republican hands in either
event he would hold great sway over this
half of congress
look at the way in which this guy is now
able to uh essentially hold hostage the
democratic party not only when it comes
to the infrastructure bill but even
within control of the senate because
understand that the majority for the
democrats right now in the senate is
kamala harris it's 50 50
50 democrats 50 republicans in terms of
caucusing bernie and angus king
independence caucus with democrats and
kamala harris is the tie-breaking vote
in the cases of 50 50.
if joe manchin does this routine but
says no i'm like bernie and angus king i
caucus with democrats
you still essentially have a 50-50
situation this is regardless of how
mansion votes on any individual bill
important to keep in mind if mansion no
longer caucuses with democrats
you have a 5149 majority for republicans
and now
mitch mcconnell takes control and has
sway over what is even a discussion in
the senate
a dramatically different situation now
as i mentioned earlier joe manchin very
quickly denied this he said the the
report is bs
period and said i have no control over
the rumors but it's bs
for all we know joe manchin
arranged to have the rumor floated
himself
because even the rumor alone is a threat
it's a threat and whether whether he's
really thinking about doing it or not
putting this out there can serve to pull
democrats over into being more
you know into placating him more uh than
they already have but ultimately what
this comes down to is does this guy in
the long term caucus with democrats or
not
he's not saying he might become a
republican
although
in basically every state but west
virginia
he's a republican i mean quite frankly
um and uh the potential of the gavel
going back to mitch mcconnell is a real
threat so
it's on the one hand maybe a carefully
crafted move to threaten this in this
way and then deny it on the other hand
it is a real threat i mean we can't you
know when when bill we spoke to bill
cher on tuesday on the show and bill
share said you know for all the
arguments about primary him or not or
this that the other thing uh if it
weren't for joe manchin being a democrat
if joe manchin were a republican or if
joe manchin was replaced with a
republican there's not even the
possibility of this bill
it's just dead and so
he does have the sway
that at the end of the day we can
say
this guy should not have the power that
he has and i'm right there with you i'm
the one who said in the first week after
the november 2020 election joe manchin
is going to have a lot of power in this
upcoming senate but i don't see the
solution being kick him out of the
democratic party or primary him which
probably leads in west virginia to a
republican winning the only solution is
win more seats now if you lose mansion
but gain two seats or three seats or
four seats you've still got a majority
okay
but uh just just saying let's figure out
how to get rid of joe manchin it just
doesn't check out mathematically and uh
the problem is democrats don't have more
seats at the end of the day so we'll see
how this uh what what happens um but joe
manchin denying the rumor i don't think
i would put too much weight into that
because of all the reasons we mentioned
let me know what you think
we have the unsurprising
revelation
which i've mentioned a half a dozen
times in the last year and a half of the
pandemic
that covet conspiracies are linked to
and pushing people towards
anti-semitism
this shouldn't really surprise too many
people if you've been watching this show
and we're going to talk about this new
report which is very interesting
um technology review has a summary
of the report by charlotte g which says
coveted conspiracy theories are driving
people to anti-semitism online old and
overtly anti-semitic fantasies are
gaining new utterance adherence
depending on your preference and
far-right activists have been working to
convert anti-lockdown beliefs into
anti-semitism too so it's happening both
ways
a warning conspiracy theories about
covid are helping disseminate
anti-semitic beliefs to a wider audience
warns a new report by the anti-racist
advocacy group hope not hate
the report says not only has the
pandemic revived interest in the new
world order conspiracy theory of a
secret jewish-run elite that claims to
that aims to run the world but far-right
activists have also worked to convert
people's anti-lock down and anti-vaccine
beliefs into active anti-semitism worst
offenders the authors easily managed to
find anti-semitism on all nine platforms
they investigated including tiktok
instagram twitter and youtube some of it
uses coded language to avoid detection
and moderation algorithms much of it is
overt and discoverable unsurprisingly
the authors found a close link between
the amount of anti-semitism on a
platform and how lightly or loosely it
is moderated the laster the moderation
the bigger the problem of anti-semitism
we've talked before
about how
shadow government new world order
conspiracy theories have a lot of
different flavors many of which are
anti-semitic um we we've talked about
that for a long time so that's one kind
of piece of this but the report which is
really very much worth looking at has an
entire section we're going to link to it
in the description to the youtube clip
for the story called conspiracy
ideologies covet 19 and anti-semitism
and i would you know go through it it
has a bunch of different uh ways in
which all of this stuff links to
anti-semitism one aspect of this is a
lot of new world order one world
government shadow government coveted
conspiracies are interlinked with
widespread and long-standing
anti-semitic conspiracies where the
people doing the shadow government are
the jews
um could be
mixed in with
the bilderbergs or
the trilateral commission or it's the
rothschilds or you know there's
different kind of flavors of it but new
world order shadow government very much
linked to anti-semitism number two
sometimes it's just the individuals they
blame are jewish individuals soros is
one classic example
the other aspect of this that we've seen
is the trivialization of the holocaust
in covid conspiracies the wearing of the
yellow stars um or of the
uh
syringe swastikas that we've seen
floating around that's been happening a
lot and that's mentioned here so the
article the report rather
talks about anti-semitism as a
conspiracy tradition just like
most of these conspiratorial uh enclaves
have anti-semitic jew hatred there
it specifically talks about these
various trivializations of the holocaust
it talks about the role of the internet
specifically and that's a section that's
very much worth looking at
um it talks about the spread of
anti-semitic conspiracy ideologies
during the pandemic in europe it talks
about 5g 5g you know again
you have to understand how all of these
tropes go together but they have the
jewish control of business thing and 5g
is a business thing and so you have that
blending together quite quite easily
um it goes into specific examples in
different countries and the list of
countries is so long as you can see here
that i'm not going to read it all to you
and the other aspect of this is
far-right recruitment from the
conspiracy scene so this is just even
folks who fall for one conspiracy theory
or another related to kovid and then end
up in these facebook groups or different
circles even if they are not
previously anti-semitic
or even link the covet stuff to
anti-semitism
the anti-semitic right-wingers white
nationalists etc know that these are
fertile recruiting grounds
for pulling people into the next step
and if they already have started to
believe there's a some kind of one world
conspiracy or involving soros and
bankers and bill gate you know whatever
i know bill gates isn't jewish but the
point is if you're already in that
universe
to say well you know have you noticed
that a lot of the people that are part
of this thing
happen to be jewish and here's a whole
bunch of other things that jews are
responsible for and then also i mean i
don't i think it's worth mentioning
um the idea
of jews as caring disease
spreading disease which is a very very
old idea so
many of us
intuitively suspected that there were um
there was mixed in right
anti-semitism into a lot of this stuff
the signals were all there sometimes
it's explicit sometimes it's implicit
and here it's sort of like an all of the
above type of scenario so check out the
report from hope not hate i don't think
you'll find anything particularly
shocking if you've been following
anti-semitism for any period of time but
the detail with which they break it down
and show you how you know in albania
here's how it's manifesting versus in
the netherlands and spain it's taking
this other um uh it has this other
flavor
very well done and very interesting so
check that out let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter at dpakman
we're going to take a quick break and
we've got a tremendous program for you
today
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 percent off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
all right let's keep going uh remember
that we do depend on folks like you
signing up on our website to fund the
program to fund staff salaries and
health insurance and all of these things
i would love for you to sign up on my
website joinpacman.com you get a bunch
of great member benefits including an
extra show that we do just for our
members every single day
joinedpakman.com is the place also
another invitation this one free this
one costs nothing join the discussion on
the david pakman show subreddit which
you can find at davidpakman.com
reddit about 33 000 believe it or not
and some many people don't believe it um
about 33 000 of our viewers and
listeners are now subscribed to the
subreddit a few posts i spotted this
morning that i thought were interesting
one user who goes by the moniker fallen
knight says dave rubin is becoming one
of the more dangerous voices on the
right
this may sound like a joke but i've
noticed dave rubin's language get more
and more extreme i used to watch a show
years ago until it turned into a
libertarian echo chamber he's very
obviously a [ __ ] and a grifter however
his use of the word evil to describe any
from anything from left-wing pundits to
media outlets to the government is
becoming more and more common this is
hardly a societal barometer but his
twitter feed and youtube videos are
filled with people foaming at the mouth
with contempt for liberals i've noticed
this more on his channel than even some
of the more well-known pundits like ben
shapiro yeah i think what might be going
on if you look at ruben's youtube
channel stats which we did on a stream
not long ago as some people mentioned it
the views on his channel are extremely
low and it almost seems like the cachet
of him abandoning the left and going to
the right and you know all the stuff and
being a trump supporter
the initial jolt from that maybe is
fading and so when that happens
sometimes people have to keep upping the
ante becoming more and more salacious
in order to titillate their audience
that may be going on i'm not really sure
but i'd be curious to hear from the
audience about what you think is going
on with dave rubin if you're paying
attention
user dragon fruit still dragon fruit is
delicious i have to tell you
says argument against trump run in 2024
and writes if trump runs again in 2024
would it not be a humorous argument to
make that since he never lost his
re-election campaign that he's
ineligible to run in 24 due to term
limits there's no real hope that this
lawsuit would succeed other than forcing
trump and his campaign to admit that he
did lose the prior election yeah this
has been brought up before which is
it's this sort of like funny idea you
have to you have to enter the world of
stupid in order to even think this way
but if trump really did win in november
of 2020
then really he can't run in 24 because
that would be his third term but i i'm
sure that they would argue it they get
they know how to defeat that and they
would say
you can't serve
you can't be elected and serve
more than two terms and although we
believe trump won in november of 2020 he
didn't serve a second term and therefore
is still eligible like they would easily
defeat that but of course you're you're
making an astute point
a user reflex point on the subreddit is
worried
about the democratic party
and says do we have any charismatic
leaders in the pipeline who do you think
the future up and comers are the type of
democrat that could win big in the
post-biden era i remember when obama
gave a speech at the dnc in 2004 and
even though i'd never heard of him i
knew right away he was going to be
president one day i just didn't think it
would be so soon after but nobody right
now
is giving me that rising star feeling
like obama did in o4 i know some will
probably say aoc
but honestly i don't think she'd be ever
ever be viable in a nationwide election
so i don't i don't know
anytime anybody says never about
anything in american politics i step
away because
you know
would would many would many of us would
have said someone like donald trump will
never be president trump will never be
president
and we would have all been wrong
um so i i don't know that i'm ready to
say aoc could never be viable nationally
but if you want to think about who's
charismatic i think john ossoff is an
interesting character um he has the
potential to get pretty pretty you know
prominent depending on his path in the
senate he's the georgia senator
democratic senator i think he's uh quite
charismatic um in some sense
you know i i find so much and i during
the 2020 democratic primary i found so
much about
pete buddha judge not particularly
thrilling but i do think that if he
continues to
um you know crush these right-wing hosts
on tv and
be the kind of articulate guy that he is
maybe maybe pete bootage would have a
bright political future
um he's a very good communicator as some
people are pointing out i think at one
point i might have wondered about gavin
newsom but i don't i don't know i think
he's sort of beleaguered right now
um
eric garcetti i i don't know i mean i'm
struggling to come up with really
exciting figures let's put it that way
and um i i think it's a concern for
democrats like who are the up-and-coming
charismatic leaders i'm not so sure
join the discussion on the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit all right this your i think
you're just going to absolutely love the
absurdity of this
after
much waiting and excitement and
anticipation and waiting with baited
breath
he's finally done it donald trump has
announced
his new media group and a new free
speech platform
called truth social
finally you will be freed from the
chains of twitter and facebook and
youtube and instagram and tick tocks and
all these different places that suppress
your speech you will have full free
speech on truth social
except not really let's go through this
piece by piece
first the announcement
tmtg
announcing this is yesterday late
yesterday
announcing trump media and technology
group
trump media and technology group and
digital world acquisition corporation
have entered into a definitive merger
agreement providing for a business
combination that will result in trump
media and technology group becoming a
publicly listed company subject to
regulatory and stockholder approval the
transaction values trump media and
technology group at an initial
enterprise value of
875 million dollars wow
with a potential additional earn out of
825 million dollars in additional shares
um going on to say
trump media and technology group's
mission is to create a rival to the
liberal media consortium and fight back
against the big tech companies of
silicon valley which have used their
unilateral power to silence opposing
voices in america just wait until what
i'm going to show you goes up on the
screen uh trump media and technology
group will soon be launching a social
network named truth social truth social
is now available for pre-order in the
apple app store truth social plans to
begin its beta launch for invited guests
in november of 21 a nationwide rollout
is expected in the first quarter of 22
you can sign up at truthsocial.com trump
the chairman of the trump media and
technology group stated
imagine trump is a tech ceo i created
truth social and tmtg to stand up to the
tyranny of big tech we live in a world
where the taliban has a huge presence on
twitter yet your favorite american
president has been silenced this is
unacceptable says trump i am excited to
send out my first truth on truth social
very soon tmtg was founded with a
mission to give voice to all wow that's
great i'm excited to soon begin sharing
my thoughts on truth social and fight
back against big tech everyone asks me
sir why doesn't someone stand up to big
tech
well we all we will be soon
don jr already appearing last night on
um fox news to promote it and it's going
to be an exercise in unfettered free
speech for all anything goes folks and
free
network for people to be able to
communicate to exercise your first
amendment rights right and so tonight my
father signed a definitive merger
agreement uh to form what will
ultimately be the trump media and
technology funny how don calls it a
definitive merger agreement yet the
announcement said it's all subject to
approval but okay that's not the focus
energy group and truth social a platform
for everyone to express their feelings
big tech and all of those on the left
for so long sean have been saying well
if you don't like the rules that we
really enforce only one way on our
platforms go create your own right and
so we did just that so that's going to
launch very soon we're going to be in
beta testing in the next few weeks
full launch uh first quarter of 22. yeah
it's going to be exciting and we're
looking to give a voice back to the
american people wow well that's all
really really exciting express your
feelings no censorship all of this stuff
it's great except
uh oh
the terms of service of trump's truth
social
don't allow criticizing truth social
uh oh
what's going on
uh the 23rd rule
which i'm putting up on the screen for
trump's planned social media site is
you can't make fun of or criticize his
social media site number 23 you are not
allowed to quote disparage
tarnish or otherwise harm
wait a second in our opinion
us and or the site
folks that's not very free speechy isn't
it and it's important to mention
on facebook you can criticize facebook
on youtube you can criticize youtube
we've done it when we feel we've been
treated unfairly by youtube we publish
it to youtube and it's fine on twitter
you can criticize twitter on instagram
you can criticize instagram they don't
ban people for criticizing them um and
yet
on the trump social site which is all
about freedom and free speech and
everybody
no censorship
you are not allowed to criticize the
site itself now
at the at the risk of getting a little
bit into the weeds the other funny thing
about this
is that the terms of service also
include a dispute resolution clause
that uh trump's lawyers
just got done arguing are unenforceable
in a different venue according to brad
heath who's the dc crime and justice
reporter the the rules for trump's site
have this uh dispute resolution thing
which says any dispute controversy or
claim you have arising uh related to
these terms of service a breach thereof
or your use of the site shall be
exclusively submitted and decided by
binding arbitration administered by the
american arbitration association any
legal action of whatever nature brought
against us
uh brought by us against you may be
commenced or prosecuted in the state and
federal courts in broward county and you
consent to the same so basically they're
saying if you come after us it's all
going to be handled by this arbitration
association which is great for them but
if we bring a cause against you it's
going to court and this is exactly this
is exactly what trump's lawyers just got
done arguing is actually not enforceable
so they don't care about principles of
free speech or no censorship they don't
care about principles when it comes to
arbitration they'll argue one thing if
it's good for them and they'll argue the
opposite if it's good for them and we
know this because even now
they only care about
censorship and silencing in terms of
service when they perceive that a
right-wing voice is being limited which
sometimes happens when they're inciting
violence or spreading horrible
disinformation but now
they don't care about those very same
principles as i've told you hundreds of
times and here is more proof it's just
about what benefits us right right now
these people are pathetic and maybe just
as pathetic trump's social media site
was already hacked so i already told you
about the the announcement of trump's
truth social social media site which
doesn't even allow you to criticize it
on its own site not very free speechy
this is just a funny coda on this story
trump's truth social was hacked within
hours of the announcement uh newsweek
reporting
former president trump's new social
media platform reportedly hacked within
hours of its announcement
uh people were able to the truth social
app will begin a beta test for invited
guests in november but people were able
to sign up to create accounts using a
publicly available link drew harwell a
tech reporter for the washington post
said on twitter i literally just
registered mike pence the site hasn't
even launched and it's already
vulnerable in a subsequent tweet he
revealed that account
had been suspended and if we look at uh
actually i don't have access to it
in the immediate um but already uh
problematic in another tweet harwell
said it appeared the donald j trump
account on truth social had been hacked
a screenshot harwell shared showed the
pinned post was of a defecating animal
however it's not clear if the account
belongs to trump right
the the trump may have posted a picture
of a defecating animal it's not clear
but
it appears as though
it's probably been hacked it's it's been
censored here so that it's
family-friendly um so that's pretty
exciting meanwhile mikhail thalin a
reporter for the daily dot tweeted he
was able to create an account using the
handle donald trump before the public
domain for the site was taken down was
just able to set up an account using the
handle donald trump on truth social
although the site isn't open a url was
discovered allowing users to sign up
anyway
um it's now been taken offline complete
and total chaos
absolutely complete in total chaos so
already apparently hacked and vulnerable
which is pretty similar to what we saw
happening with the mike pillow platform
as well so a lot of things going wrong
quickly in the early hours my prediction
trump's truth social platform is going
to lead to a lot a lot of comedy we'll
have more on this on the david pakman
show instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today from my undergraduate alma mater
dr peg riley professor at umass amherst
who runs an undergraduate research lab
focused on the discovery and
pre-clinical testing of novel
anti-microbials great to have you on i
appreciate your time
my pleasure so okay i mean maybe just to
get into this and eventually we're going
to kind of relate this to
uh the covet virus and the um suggestion
of things like ivermectin or or
azithromycin for possible treatment or
mitigation when we think about
antibiotics to treat illness generally
what are the sort of issues that we
worry about coming up including
antibiotic resistance at a population
level and other things
sure well as most of your viewers will
know we use antibiotics in medicine
to either prevent or eliminate an
infection by bacteria
so they're very powerful fantastic they
developed the name magic bullet for good
reason they'll wipe out
a staph infection or what have you
rapidly now when we first started using
those in the 1950s
we didn't understand that we live with a
microbiome
and that means we have bacteria and
other microbes in us on us around us and
they're making us healthy by and large
but antibiotics don't know the
difference between what's a healthy
microbe in our microbiome and what's the
pathogen we want it to kill
so when you take an antibiotic for a
strep throat or an ear infection or
something much more
serious
you stand the chance of really wiping
out a lot of the good bacteria in your
gut the lactobacilli the bifidobacter
all those things that you hear about in
kimchi and yogurt well all of those can
be decimated as well
and so
when we take antibiotics when we
shouldn't which is actually quite often
we could potentially make our health
worse rather than better
when we think about the long term of
antibiotic use
if i if my research is is correct
there's only a few types of antibiotics
even though there's many
specific ones there's really only a few
families is the path forward that
eventually some new type of antibiotic
medication will be will be necessary
well i sure hope so david or we're not
going to survive long
are now in what we call the post
antibiotic era and that was designated
by the world health organization about
seven years ago now
where
we have used abused and overused
antibiotics to the point where we have
pathogens that that can cause fatal
disease in humans that no longer respond
to antibiotics
and i want to throw in one other
sideline here which we often don't think
about in point of fact
eighty percent of our antibiotics are
not used for human health
they're used by the agricultural systems
to either produce fatter healthier pigs
or to keep blight off of apples or
tomatoes
and so
we're basically using these critical
drugs designed for humans originally
to
make food cheaper and that's something
that society has to talk about and
decide if that's a good route to be
taking
when we talk about the types of
antimicrobials
that you work on and and look at
developing what's different about those
versus antibiotics
great question so with an antibiotic it
is designed it is chosen by a
pharmaceutical company because it kills
as much as possible in other words as
many bacterial species as is possible
and the reason is the cost of developing
and and getting through clinical trials
and antibiotic it's it's several billion
dollars
now picture that i have urinary tract
infection and i want to take a drug to
treat it
that's almost always called by caused by
e coli which is a species bacteria in
your gut in my gut normally doesn't
bother us in fact we're happy to have it
for lots of reasons but when it gets
into our urinary tract system it causes
problems for some people so imagine that
i could give you a pill that didn't kill
everything in your microbiome but just
killed e coli
now
picture that world now my microbiome is
happy
i've killed the e coli
and the selection for what you mentioned
earlier antibiotic resistance is much
lower
so when i take a conventional antibiotic
any bacterium in my body
that can have a mutation that will cause
it to be able to resist that drug to
fight it off
will be selected for and they'll
increase in frequency in my body and
that's what's happened over the last 50
years that's why we have multi-drug or
totally drug-resistant pathogens to deal
with
so let's maybe now introduce the topic
of of covid19
we've seen the suggestions and some of
these things have been studied
that
azithromycin known as zythromax
or or zpac
even though it's an antibiotic and
covid19 is a virus that in some
situations it can have an antiviral
property and maybe it should be
uh used for treating covid19 the
the the placebo-controlled studies i've
seen
don't seem to show that it actually does
work in in that way but it is something
that's being studied anti-parasitic
ivermectin hydroxychloroquine
etc uh what are their properties to some
of these that could work at least
theoretically when you're dealing with a
virus
well what they might do
is
impact something in your body that then
helps you weather covet better
does that make sense yeah because these
drugs are not designed to kill a virus
it's in fact very challenging for us to
come up with medications that will kill
viruses
and that's why we don't have a lot of
them it's not that we haven't tried
heaven forbid we've actually tried very
hard
now a
a drug to kill a protist
a drug to to kill a bacterium could
impact you because maybe you have an
underlying condition
that is caused by bacterium or protists
and that when you get covid it
exasperates either the covet or
exasperates the underlying condition and
so
possibly that's why some people report
feeling better
when they take ivermectin for example
now personally
i'm a scientist i believe in data and
until the fda tells me or shows me
better yet
the clinical trials
that means double-blind
placebo-based trials and for those who
don't know what that means that means
the doc who's administering the trial
has no idea which patient got which
that they cannot bias their
interpretation of a patient's state
status of health because they don't know
who got the sugar pill
and that's the gold standard and that's
why it takes so long to get drugs
approved by fda those are tough studies
to carry out especially during a
pandemic
when uh when we
think about the way in which sometimes
one medication or a few over time like
at one point it was hydroxychloroquine
azithromycin plus zinc with or without
zinc ivermectin etc when we think about
these things entering the kind of media
discussion and becoming popularized
sometimes on one political side or
sometimes more broadly what do you think
underlies this is it that when there's
cheap widely available medications
around
and no clear treatment doctors say let's
just try let's throw something at it and
just kind of see what happens is that
the genesis of a lot of these things
you know i've never spoken to a medical
doctor who would have used any of those
oh alternatives
so i can't respond directly what i can
tell you is if we compare this to
vaccine hesitancy for example
and i teach classes of 400
undergraduates none of whom are science
majors and many of them start out in my
class
agreeing that they are hesitant about
getting vaccinated and it came from
their parents or from their neighborhood
or what have you and it's really an
anxiety
because you don't understand the science
and we scientists haven't taken the time
to find ways to help you understand the
science so i blame the scientists not
the
anti-vaxxers
well
do you think yeah a better
what tends to work in the classes at
changing the perspective on vaccination
i show them the history of the success
of vaccines
i show them how a clinical trial is
designed
how it's interpreted what are the
issues that one has to confront when
interpreting the data so without diving
into the details i give them the sense
of how rigorous
science particularly science that is
being used to impact human health
is is carried out under and the
incredible role the fda plays in being
the gatekeeper
because there are a lot of scientists
that are
so excited about their ideas i mean my
drugs i would love to give them to my
neighbors right now i would love to but
none of them are fda approved so i can't
right
and you can't help but be excited about
your your drug or your idea
and that could be tempting in a time
where there's a pandemic where
individuals are dying if there's
something why not try it that's the sort
of attitude
maybe that accounts for why medical
professionals would do this
but i urge them to stop
when it comes to the big picture impact
of this period of time during which
people are maybe washing their hands
more frequently
wearing masks
not being around people as much one fear
that some have expressed is
this may attenuate the strength of one's
immune system merely by stopping a lot
of these little interactions with
different sorts of pathogens that you
interact with all the time and you sort
of build build resistance to so that you
may come out of the pandemic not having
gotten covered but maybe generally less
protected from an immune immunity
standpoint against things we encounter
on a regular basis is there something to
that how long would one
have to be
you know isolated from pathogens and and
the other question is if you're still
eating food from grocery stores and
going to the gas station occasionally
are you even really fully isolated from
pathogens anyway
thank you that's a great question and a
great point you made at the end so first
of all one of the greatest impacts on
this new approach to life wherein
masking isolation separation six feet or
more is going to be found in the nursing
homes and it already is being found in
the nursing homes their microbiomes are
far less diverse on average than an
individual who may be just isolated in
their home with family members
so we know that and less diverse
microbiomes in general are not as what
we would call healthy they're not as
able to stimulate our immune system just
as you were talking about a moment ago
but we don't live in vacuums and we
don't live in sterile chambers and so
going for a walk um getting a little
dirt on your hands believe it or not
eating the kinds of foods you were
talking about apples and high fiber
fiber rich diets are going to stimulate
the good microbes that are already
possibly present in your gut and and get
you back into the realm you want to be
so certainly eating fermented foods is
always a good idea
that helps
get the microbes enriched in your body
that are so protective
like lactobacilli or bifidobacter
so for the average person who had a year
and a half of less socializing
and wearing a mask went out for example
is that really going to impact their
immune system in in a significant way
i don't have the data to answer that
question but i can tell you from a sort
of practical perspective
good as masks are that does not keep any
of us from using our hands to touch
things right and it not keep any of us
from walking inside and touching our
face or our arm or what have you so
again we're not living in a sterile
environment we're
limiting the spread of things that carry
easily in the air that's what we're
doing and that's why flu
essentially evaporated last year right
and in fact i i went back and watched in
a lecture that i gave to my kids in this
big class of non-scientists i remember
right at the beginning of the covid um
pandemic before it was a pandemic they
were still in the class with me 400 of
them in an auditorium
and i said you know guys i'm going to
let you go today because we're getting
signs that this is highly infectious but
there's good news on the horizon i said
you won't get flu this year right and
they just laughed as they were happy to
leave the lecture room
and it turned out to be quite quite
accurate in fact oh yes i mean it was
easy to predict i mean you wear masks
you don't touch each other
gee i wonder what will happen with flu
right right yeah that'll be interesting
to see this this flu season that is
that's coming right now um dr peg riley
professor at umass amherst really
appreciate your time and your insights
today
thank you very much for inviting me to
join you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show a ton of you asked me to talk about
this recent barry weiss appearance on
cnn barry weiss was a reporter for the
new york times and left under
circumstances where she claimed that
her views basically weren't welcome she
was ostracized she was made to feel
uncomfortable so she went and launched a
sub stack and she appeared on cnn with
brian stelter we're going to look at the
clip now i i want to mention
i am no fan of brian stelter like brian
stelter is very controversial in like
media right-wing media circles a lot of
people don't like him i don't really
care about brian stelter he said some
things that i agree with and sometimes
he's kind of wacky whatever you know
this is not an adjudication of brian
stelter barry weiss sometimes she says
things that i i find sensible and
sometimes she makes no sense but this
clip is being made out to be sort of
like this um incredible takedown of the
media establishment by barry weiss for
the things that people aren't allowed to
talk about
my perspective and i'll tell you up
front
rather than saving it for the end my
perspective on this is that it is the
exact type of hyperbole about so-called
cancel culture and censorship that
really is barely going on and a lot of
right-wingers love this i think it's all
pretty dumb let's just jump right into
it and take a listen you write there are
tens of millions of americans who aren't
on the hard left or the hard right who
feel the world has gone mad so in what
ways has the world gone mad
well you know when you have the chief
reporter on the beat of kovid for the
new york times talking about how
questioning or pursuing the question of
the lab leak is racist the world has
gone mad okay now
i agree with her there
investigating
whether
something came from a certain country
absent anything else is not inherently
racist
it was used
to justify and it fueled xenophobia
against asian americans
but simply saying
did this come from a lab in china that
is not inherently racist that that i
agree with when you're not able to say
out loud and in public that there are
differences between men and women the
world has gone mad that's absurd
you can find some places
where
i mean i guess someone might be saying
there are no differences between men and
women i've still not seen that and i
know that the right loves to talk about
that when they say it's not that we hate
trans people it's that you're not even
allowed to say there's a difference
between men i've just not seen that i'm
not i've seen no evidence that that's
the case when we're not allowed to
acknowledge that rioting is rioting and
it is bad
i again
when we saw
by the way rioting the real riots were
january 6th then many of the people
claiming that police brutality protests
were riots won't call what happened on
the sixth a riot like put that hypocrisy
aside
the left that i'm a part of and that i
see
says
destruction of property and violence as
part of protests is bad
who's not allowed to say that and that
silence is not violence but violence is
violence the world has gone mad when
we're not able to say that hunter
biden's laptop is a story worth pursuing
the world has gone mad the story has
been pursued the story has that that's
she seems now to be taking issue with
the fact that
many media outlets looked at the story
and said it just doesn't meet the
evidentiary rigor for us to publish it
when in the name of progress young
school children as young as kindergarten
are being separated in public schools
because of their race now that i don't
even know what she's talking about i
looked into that
i just couldn't find that i don't know
what she's talking about with that one
and that is called progress rather than
segregation the world has gone mad there
are dozens of examples that i could
share with with you and you always say
you say aloud sort of knows this and
you say we're not allowed we're not able
who's the people stopping the
conversation who are they
um people let work at networks frankly
like the one i'm speaking on right now
who try and claim that you know it was
it was racist to investigate the lab
leak theory it was i mean who said that
in cnn right she's she's repeating she
she had one example from one person at
the new york times
you know
almost no one is saying that that's not
a predominant opinion anywhere i'm just
saying that when you say allowed i just
think it's a provocative thing you say
you say you say we're not allowed to
talk about these things but they're all
over the internet i can google them i
can find them everywhere i've heard
about every story you mentioned so i'm
just suggesting of course people are
allowed to cover whatever they want to
cover but you and i both know and it
would be delusional to claim otherwise
that touching your finger to an
increasing number of subjects that have
been deemed third rail by the mainstream
institutions and increasingly by some of
the tech companies will lead to
reputational damage perhaps you losing
your job
your children sometimes being demonized
as well and now it starts to get like
very very outrageous so what happens is
a kind of internal self-censorship ah so
now she shifts to well it's not actually
that no one's allowed to talk about it
it's that people are self-censoring now
does self-censorship exist in some cases
sure i've talked about how i've
self-censored in in some cases
but this is very similar to when uh you
know the big thing was oh uh the left is
just overrun with identity politics but
no at the time it was like yeah identity
politics in the women's march got a
little toxic and saying jewish women
aren't intersectional enough to be part
of th that was going on but by and large
the left at that time was concerned with
economic issues and environment and the
start of the pandemic and all these
different things
this is always the idea they exaggerated
and they say this is an epidemic this is
crazy
and then when you say well so who's not
allowed to talk well you're allowed but
you might suffer reputational damage or
people are self-censoring or whatever
the case may be but then with a lot of
these examples there's there's it's
literally one example one example and
the issue of uh the you know the origins
of kovid it's been looked at everywhere
we've talked about it we didn't shy away
a lot of other you know colleagues on
the left have looked at it at it what
she wants fundamentally what she wants
there are so many people that think she
really crushed cnn and the media
establishment there
all she did was argue for freedom from
the consequences of speech and a lot of
these people
that are sort of these anti-focused
free speech no matter what er type
people
often what they really want is freedom
from the consequences of speech and no
one gets that no one gets that and when
they say we're not allowed to talk about
they're often talking about those things
on tv shows
with global audiences and no one is
restricting their ability to talk about
that she was on cnn talking about how on
cnn you can't talk about any of these
things no one's talking over her no
one's kicking her off there are things
that cnn has talked about now to the
extent that she makes okay points like
for you know she was right there there
was that new york times reporter and
some
you know little bit of blip
about it's racist to say the virus might
have come from china no it's it's not
fundamentally racist it is racist to
then take that and attack asian
americans and discriminate against asian
people right but the entire thing seems
sort of unhinged and she seems to
conflate being allowed to talk about
things with having to take
debunked stories seriously and giving
them more and more and more and more air
time or
the freedom from the consequences of
your speech you just don't get that
nobody gets that i don't get that
nobody gets that it consequences to
speech
is part of free speech
so for me this was not a particularly
titillating clip at all and it certainly
was not the takedown that many on the
right made it out to be hey i don't want
to spend a lot of time on this but i do
want to mention it one of the things
that trump's former lawyer michael cohen
has said trump did and that we know
trump did is
the same asset if he wants to avoid
taxes he says it's not worth a lot and
if he wants to get a loan against it or
be
you know richer on the forbes list he'll
say it's worth more
we now have a specific example and it's
all related to a trump golf club the ap
reporting trump golf club reportedly
faces new criminal probe over taxes
westchester club allegedly misled
officials to reduce taxes and
fundamentally what donald trump did here
is the same golf club he said in one
place this thing's worth more than 50
million dollars and elsewhere he said
it's only worth 1.4 million dollars
rachel maddow explains it really well
let's take a look
the numbers here are sort of easy to
keep in your head the town is telling
them to pay taxes on a golf course that
they say is worth 15 million dollars
he's saying no no i won't it's only
worth 1.4 million dollars right
but that same year in 2016 he files his
financial disclosure statement as a
presidential candidate he files it in
may 2016. united states office of
government ethics executive branch
personnel public financial disclosure
report the town said the golf course
again was worth 15 million
he said no i'm not taking paying taxes
on a 15 million property it's only worth
1.4 million
but look at what he put in his official
financial disclosure that same year
his official financial disclosure line
item 93 trump national golf club
westchester county value
over 50 million dollars
so to one part of the government he's
telling them
this golf course is worth over 50
million dollars but for the tax
authorities he's saying it's 1.4 million
dollars how can something simultaneously
be worth over 50 million dollars
according to trump and only 1.4 million
dollars also according to trump how can
that be true at the same time
so this is this is actually it's really
actually quite simple this is exactly
what michael cohen described this is
exactly what has been otherwise reported
that trump does
if he needs to pump up his net worth or
he needs to borrow money he goes look at
this beautiful asset look at this
perfect golf course worth 50 million
dollars
loan me 25 million because i've got this
50 million dollar asset i can put i can
prop up as collateral for it okay on the
other hand if it's hey
you've got to pay taxes you've got to
pay taxes on this 50 million or as the
town believed it was 15 million asset
trump goes listen i don't have any money
uh first of all this is only worth 1.4
million dollars so the taxes should be
levied on that amount and i don't even
have the money to pay taxes as if it
were worth 15 million dollars this is
similar to keeping two sets of books
it's not the same it's similar to
keeping two sets of books which is not
allowed um and this is now part of this
new probe so
no big shock just another data point
that this was a technique that donald
trump used we knew it already but that's
another data point of trump's usage of
it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's an idea from a viewer's boyfriend
i believe are masks making people behave
in crazy ways
hi david um so my boyfriend pointed out
to me when we went to the grocery store
that everybody's acting a little bit
more crazy and on edge and maybe that
things will go back to normal as far as
uh people behaving normally
when the masked mandates get lifted and
i'm from el paso texas and
i told him i feel like everybody went
into like this um
mentality where they did get
jailed well not in a jail per se but
they did go into
kind of like house arrest and we were
all
they felt like they were in jail by
having to wear a mask in the house so i
mean i just wanted to get your thoughts
on that as far as
i feel like the maps have nothing to do
with the way people are behaving now i
don't know that it's the mask
specifically but i do think that to some
degree
the long period where sort of like the
rules of engagement around being around
people were changed and masks were part
of it
um changed a lot of people some people
just from being home kind of like forgot
how to socialize normally some people
are just really angry people and they're
lashing out some people are experiencing
you know sort of like a personal uh
emotional crisis mental health crisis so
i don't think it's masks per se that are
making people act in crazy ways although
some of the people are acting out saying
we shouldn't have to wear masks in that
sense it's like the
the fact that someone wants them to wear
a mask that's bothering them but i think
it's a much bigger picture thing that
hopefully hopefully will start to settle
as we hopefully get out of this pandemic
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
sign up at joinpackman.com to get
instant access to it
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman